next I'd like to present our silver
medal winner and to do that we have a
film made just up the street at UCLA by
animator mark Nelson with a rather
interesting title the jockstrap Raiders
it's actually a very funny look at a
group of misfit pilots who are excluded
from participating in world war one due
to their various abnormalities first I
just want to thank the academy for
voting for a film about a bunch of
grown-ups and grown men in jockstraps
which is kind of strange i also want to
thank everyone at the UCLA animation
workshop Dan mcLaughlin Celia Mercer
Doug Ward my brilliant voice actor Fred
tadich or my amazing composer Gordy hob
great sound designer Roland ty I also
want to thank Devin uzun Patrick Smith
Jason Thielen going Lee Anthony domani
and last but not least I want to say
thanks to my brother from the same
mother Eric Nelson who was basically
there the whole on every aspect of this
film and talked me off many alleged when
I just wanted to quit quit making it
after like four years and of course my
parents who pretty much has always been
awesome thanks